beginning with the bismillah this is the
Daily Show radio show my brother that's
right that's how we begin it beginning
with the bismillah al hamdulillah and
that's right you're listening to the
Dean show radio show now you can listen
to us on audio format in the Audio waves
we are for those who listen watch us
every week on the big screen on the
television now you can listen to us in
your cars and your iPods the podcast you
can get all of our audio shows at the
same place you can get our video shows
at the th e de and show that Dean show
calm all you gotta do is look for the
blog section and that's where we'll be
at today we're going to be discussing
the Salah the prayer when somebody puts
the key in the door that's right to open
a door you need a key and that key which
is the key to paradise is that statement
that every Muslim makes he says la
illaha illallah there is no deity worthy
of worship except Allah that's the
crater the heavens in the earth why do I
need a worship a monkey or a man why do
I work need to worship a woman or the
son of the moon why do I need to follow
my lusts and desires when I can worship
the one who created me and he can guide
me he's my GPS in life he is the one
that I'll sacrifice everything for my
life my prayer my sacrifice my death is
for the one who created me isn't that
beautiful just talking about it gives me
chills and I should get everybody chills
because Allah is the one who created you
and you're gonna have to return back to
him so now that you've taken this oath
you've committed to the One God the God
of Jesus Abraham Moses and the last and
final messenger sent to mankind the
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him all they were our teachers
but today the last and final messenger
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
he's the teacher he's the way the truth
and the light in all the darkness and
the falsehood he's the teacher why
because he's the representative of God
he's got the power of attorney that's
right just like Jesus had the power of
attorney he was able to do things by the
permission of the creator of the heavens
and earth Allah and that's the same
thing now so we testified la illaha
illallah there is no deity there is no
God worthy of worship except the one
true God in Arabic we say Allah and
Muhammad is His slave servant and final
messenger now that brings us to the
topic today of which is the prayer now
sadly very sadly to say that today many
Muslims don't pray many Muslims that's
right I said it don't pray despite its
importance the purpose of prayer we need
to know is to strengthen our
relationship with the one who created us
he don't need this prayer we need it
this prayer helps us to be grateful for
all the blessings that he's given us and
it reminds us it reminds you and me of
his greatness just as the body requires
physical needs such as food and drink
the soul requires spiritual needs that's
right nourished by acts of worship the
most important of which is the Salah the
prayer that the Muslim needs to be
making it could be that the body of a
person is healthy you know the guy goes
to the gym big boy strong lifting
hitting 350 on the bench two three four
plates same thing for the woman she's in
shape running a marathon the body is
looking good but that doesn't mean it's
alive
the body of a person is healthy I pay
attention the person is spiritually dead
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him a messenger just like Jesus at
his time just like Moses and Abraham at
their time he's the messenger and a
mercy to the world's at this time his
teachings have been preserved
authentically there for anybody who is
looking to get close to the one who
created them he is that path to God we
don't pray through him we follow his
teachings and the last and final
messenger sent to mankind has said in an
authentic hadith these are not story
tales that we tell the kids these are
instructions from God's representative
teacher to the human beings on earth the
Prophet said the comparison of the one
who remembers Allah the creator and the
one who does not is like that of the
living and the dead that was what the
messenger said now let's listen to what
Allah pay attention here what allah has
said in the verbatim word of god the
quran allah is saying o you who believe
me respond to the call of a law and his
messenger when he calls you to that
which gives you light this is in the
Quran in chapter 8 verse 24 now it's
important as we move along this is the
direction the direct connection with
Allah we don't need any intermediary we
don't need to go through anybody Allah
the Creator God Almighty is calling us
to have a direct connection with him
without anybody in the middle
the Prophet peace be upon him has said
the closest a person is to his Lord is
when he is in the prostration prayer
connects you with Allah the Arabic word
for prayer is a salad it actually
derived from the Arabic word meaning
connection a laws messenger God's final
messenger sent to the whole of mankind
has said when any one of you stands to
pray he is communicating with his Lord
with his create torso let him pay
attention to how he speaks to him so now
don't sever this relationship with your
crate or don't do it by abandoning the
prayer the pillar of Islam it's a pillar
of Islam prayer is the second most
important pillar of Islam after that
swearing to that testimony of la illaha
illa llah of what we discussed before we
started this topic that you know what
only submit to God the one who created
me that's the first pillar and the
second one is the salat and it is the
most regular compulsory action in a
Muslims life prayer is the one act that
Muslim a Muslim must be fulfilled at
least five times a day regardless of its
regardless of his circumstance in fact
the crater Allah did not even exempt
those who have submitted themselves
Muslims from praying during battle
that's right even if there was a battle
going on a law is saying guard strictly
your prayers if you fear an enemy
umbreon foot foot alright so this is the
case during war that you're not even
accept from praying their laws telling
you if you can't pray on foot pray while
you're writing on your beast on the
horse in your car doesn't matter you can
not give up the prayer so this is stated
during the time of war what about during
peace success lies in prayer the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind there is no more messengers
coming this is him he has said the first
of his deeds for which a man and woman
will be called to account on the day of
resurrection the day of judgment will be
the prayers if it is found to be sound
he will be safe and successful but if it
is defective he will be unfortunate and
a loser you don't want to be a loser do
you you want to be successful don't give
up the prayer establish the prayer
establish the Salah its benefits shields
one from evil it's a shield against all
evil without seeking a loss help it is
impossible to refrain from all this evil
that is around Allah the creator of the
heavens and the earth is saying very
rare you're strange rings oneself from
shameful and unjust days this is in the
verbatim word of God Allah in the Quran
through 25 verse 45 now the question
your ass how can sins be committed how
can sins be committed if you're
willingly standing before your Creator
Allah five times a day minimum five
times a day in the prayer the prayer now
moving along and riches your soul the
prayer enriches your soul prayers
satisfies your spiritual need to be
connected with your create or to be in
contact with your create or this gives
your soul peace and
10 min especially with this busy
lifestyle that we all live the rat race
of life and this is something that money
cannot buy a law is saying in the paren
without doubt in the remembrance of
allah do hearts find rest the prayer
makes one humble pride and arrogance is
being rid of by you realizing through
the prayer allows greatness and your
dependence on him in the prayer the
Muslim puts the highest part of his body
his head is intellect on the ground he
says how perfect is my lord the most
high how perfect is my lord the most
high super Han had a beer dad Allah is
saying in the verbatim word of God the
Quran and Sunnah 23 verses 1 and 2
successful and we'd are the believers
who are humble in their Diaries let me
tell you another fact let me tell you
what washes away sins sins are when you
break the laws of the one who created
you sins are something that feel heavy
on your chest and form black stains on
your heart everyone commits them and no
one is paying the price for your sins
not Bob the butcher not mark the mailman
nor Jesus Christ peace be upon him of
Nazareth nobody is paying the price for
your sins you are accountable for
yourself just that your grandfather was
accountable for himself and I'm
accountable for myself today but Allah
the creator of the heavens and earth has
provided for us a way to get rid of the
sins with sincere repentance
and through prayer Allah is saying in
the Quran through 11 114 and perform
free surely the good day remove the evil
deeds now the messenger peace be upon
him gave us a beautiful example when he
said to his companions he said in an
authentic narration considered one of
you had a river by his door in which he
bade five times a day what any filth
remain on him or her they responded no
then the Prophet replied peace be upon
him likewise allah your Creator wipes
away sins with the five daily prayers
that's right moving along the prayer is
the key the answer to your problems
whoever strengthens their relationship
with the one who created them Allah
Allah will strengthen their relationship
between themselves and the creation he
who is all powerful all merciful all
loving will rectify all your problems
Allah is saying in the Quran seek help
in patience and prayer the prayer unites
the Muslims the congregational prayer
this is when the Muslims come together
to pray in congregation congregation
prayer cultivates Brotherhood equality
and humility between Muslims the
worshipers stand in rows and is one body
shoulder to shoulder without any
distinction of race nationality color
wealth family or status this act of
unity helps demolish all barriers which
stand between people now we're going to
be moving on to the abandonment of
Prayer abandoning the prayer Allah the
creator of the heavens and the earth has
said in the Quran this is the
translation of the meaning the Quran is
in
and has been preserved in the Arabic but
what we're giving you here is the
meaning which can be in French it can be
in Spanish we're talking in English so
we're going to give you the meaning in
English Allah is saying all mankind what
it is see you concerning your Lord the
most gracious this is in the Quran
chapter 82 verse 6 now moving along by
not praying by not establishing a
connection with the one who created you
and this is only for your betterment for
your self development you are disobeying
the most high the Creator Allah the
Almighty you are an act of disobedience
you're breaking a peace treaty between
you and him because you enter a state of
peace when you comply with everything
that he's told you to do and one of the
most important things that second pillar
is the prayer remember the whole purpose
of your existence is to worship Allah to
be in compliance with everything good
that he's told you to do and to stay
away from everything evil that he's told
you to stay away from he knows best he's
the most wise we trust him because he's
the create or he knows his creation yet
daily you are disobeying the Creator
Allah is saying in the car and then
there has succeeded in a generation who
have given up in prayer and have
followed their desires so they will be
thrown in hell except those who repent
and believe and work righteousness this
is a new car and chapter 19 verse 59 in
another place in the Quran chapter 7 d 4
verse 42 law is saying a lie saying pay
close attention the people how will be
asked what has caused you to enter the
Hellfire they will say we were not those
who use
to train that's the speech of Allah in
the Quran the verbatim word of God he is
talking are you listening we listen to
everyone and everything but when the
most high the most gracious the most
loving when he is speaking are we
listening and are we following it up
with action now remember when you
abandon when you leave off the five
daily prayers you are being ungrateful
refusing your creators invitation to
establish this close relationship with
him is the ultimate ingratitude a law
created you and remember he gave you
everything Allah is saying in the car
and it is he who has created you and
endowed you with hearing and seeing and
hearts little are not grateful the
Prophet peace be upon him the last and
final messenger sent of mankind his feet
would swell because he would stand in
the night he was 10 in the day for long
periods of time praying and when he was
asked about this he replied should I not
be grateful should I not be a grateful
servant to my lord what excuse will you
give a law in the create or the crater
of the heavens and the earth on the day
of judgment not just envision this def
comes the one who has blessed you of 24
hours in a day yet only asks you to
spend merely 30 minutes for prayer what
would you tell him on the day of
judgment on the day that no attorney no
City no government nobody will be able
to enter see nobody be able to help not
any amount of money status kingship it
doesn't matter who you know where you
been on the day of judgment what are you
going to say Allah is saying in the
Quran chapter 20 verse 1 24 pay
attention people and whoever turns away
from my remembrance indeed for him is a
life a partridge
and we will raise him up on the Day of
Resurrection line and he will say my
lord why raise line while I was would
see a law will say does that our size
come to me and you forgot the scarred
and thus will you this day ain't
forgotten your only harming yourself
this is affect a lot doesn't need your
prayer or anything from anybody glory be
to him so behind a law as we say it is
you that stands in need of his mercy
Allah is saying in the Quran which the
meaning is in verse 31 12 give thanks to
Allah and whoever gives snakes it is
only for his own soul and whoever is on
a grapefruit sure law is free with all
means worthy of all praise let this be
known also that when a person abandons
the prayer you are flirting with
disbelief many scholars of Islam hold
the opinion that if you do not pray you
are one who has disbelieved you become a
disbeliever quoting the following hadith
from the last and final messenger the
Prophet Muhammad who has said the
covenant between us and them the
Covenant which distinguish says between
us and them between believers and
disbelievers is the salat is the prayer
and whoever neglects it has disbelieved
this is what the last and final
messenger sent to mankind has said in
authentic hadith additionally the
prophets companions those who knew him
the best who lived at his time may Allah
be pleased with them they did not
consider the abandonment of any act as
disbelief except the prayer let's move
along to some common excuses that people
use to justify why they don't pray now
these are a dime a dozen let's be
sincere with ourselves as we listen to
these the people say those say I have no
time work
I have to work studying I have to study
for school I'm busy I have no time
because I am preoccupied with many of
the worldly things this is pure and
simple deception you haven't given
prayers priority this is the fact Allah
will bless your time and make you more
effective efficient and successful
because he is the one who gives success
he is the one who provides for you so if
you're not doing what he told you to do
you can only be unsuccessful another
common excuse we hear is my heart is
clean the fact is that a lot judges who
has clean hearts and he wants you to
pray he's the boss he is the king of
kings actions will reflect what is in
your heart no one has a cleaner heart
than the last and final messenger
prophet muhammad peace be upon him who
used to pray regularly another excuse we
have is my alarm it's hard for your
alarm to go off if you don't set it
purify your intention go to sleep with
the intention of getting up and a lot
will make it easy for you another excuse
that we hear is my family my spouse's my
parents friends prevent me the Prophet
peace be upon him said the last and
final messenger sent to mankind there is
no obedience to anyone in the
disobedience to Allah this is very
important we respect our parents and
were kind to the people but we never
obeyed them fear them in place of
obeying Allah fearing and loving Allah
we love him the most we obey Him before
we obey anyone else remember again you
will be judged alone another common
excuse I'm sinning too much
the fact that a matter is in time your
prayers will prevent you from committing
these sins in time just pray you are
sinning because you are not establishing
the prayer the prayer is the medicine
the prayer will eventually repel the
evil Allah has told the truth stick to
what he told you to do cut out the
excuses contemplate over the Sun deef
where the Prophet peace be upon him had
said if they knew the merits of the
ishan fudger prayers they will come to
them in the mosque even if they had to
crawl now what excuse for a banning
prayer do you honestly have when you
face your Lord on that difficult day on
that difficult day Allah is saying in
the Quran Allah has promised all those
who believe and do good release
therefore if a man there is forgiveness
and a mighty reward now brothers and
sisters we can do one of two things we
can either turn away after this advice
and continue living our lives according
to our whims and desires thinking that
we know best or we can be sincere with
ourselves we can admit that you know
what we don't have the answers to
everything and we need the craters help
and he's there willing to help us we
take one step towards him he takes many
more towards us He loves us more than
our mothers morden our family and
friends and he knows what's best for us
because he is the most wise so we can
start to comply and little by little
by establishing this prayer we will see
that affects the great effects of
goodness that it will have in our life
nothing's easy at first anything that's
of importance and value it takes some
effort so the same way you put effort
into getting that degree into chasing
that man or woman or those good times
the sins now you have to put a little
bit of effort into something that's more
valuable than any of these things the
connection with the one who has given
you life and he'll give you death we
will all die and remember is it worth it
when you're six feet under and the dirt
is in your mouth and now everything that
distracted you from praying because it's
one of these things it's either that man
or that woman it's either that material
thing that job that business it's
something in this dunya that's
distracting you so when you're dead when
you hear the footsteps of your family
leaving and walking away from the grave
envision that and they go back to fight
over your wealth that you are so
earnestly seeking in this life and it
was distracting you from your Lord now
is it worth it you got a chance to hear
this advice by the blessing of the one
who created you now you can either do
something about it or you can turn a
blind eye and we sincerely out of our
love for you want us we want to see you
do the right thing establish the
connection with the one who loves you
more than anyone and wants you in that
paradise those are the glad tidings that
all the messengers came with they all
came they all came with that glad tiding
of paradise and the warning of the
hellfire because we know how it is to
get someone to move and Allah knows best
is that carried in that stick
the carrot there's something more
pleasurable than that that were chasing
and that's the pleasure of our Lord in
his paradise and there's something that
we fear more than that stick and that's
the Hellfire and even if you think about
it when your boss wants you to comply
with what he wants you to do he'll tell
you you better get to wit it or you'll
be fired but with Allah the fire is what
allah is talking about so we don't want
to be in the Hellfire Allah wants us in
the paradise let's start to comply and
fear a lot more and love a lot more than
the people because this prayer will help
us will develop us to be better human
beings to be better with our parents to
be better with our colleagues our
friends and our family it will help us
to develop to be the best of human
beings with everyone non Muslims and
Muslims alike to all of humanity we have
to run we gotta go remember to share our
shows with everybody remember to visit
us at the Dean show and for the audio
podcast at the Dean show com blog be
kind be gentle don't be harsh with the
people spread the greetings of peace
we'll see you next time inshallah God
won't even Salam alaikum peace be unto
you
you